lex megatrends
city scenarios from singapore on thames
to the spires of gaia the city of london
has been many things
roman trading outpost financier to the
british empire
and deregulated yuppie playground
now brexit is eroding its position as
europe's financial hub
the city needs reinventing how do
different scenarios stack up the
first is repressed rule taker
odds 30-1 city bosses hoped brexit would
bring
little disruption the uk would mirror eu
financial regulation but the eu is not
granting equivalence for city businesses
to operate on an equal footing with
locals by requiring eu investors to
onshore
trading and clearing progressively the
eu can make
lots of non-eu capital switch too
before more than half the trade in eu
equities was in london
now less than a fifth is
the second scenario is singapore on
thames
odds three to one the south
east asia hub serves a whole region just
as london serves
emea countries it's also a forum
for inter-regional deal making
regulation is seen as
flexible but muscular singapore is a
welcoming city for expat financiers
top rate personal tax is just 22
corporate tax is only 17
that wouldn't work in the uk which is
raising corporation tax
to 25 percent authoritarianism is
another singaporean trait
the uk wouldn't copy regulatory style
is a bigger deal breaker the uk would
need to adopt the agile
economically driven approach of
singapore's monetary authority
the uk's slow-moving financial conduct
authority
would need a heavy overhaul but
overzealous deregulation could trigger
the third scenario
dodge city odds 7-1
the uk may let founders wield extra
votes over premium listed companies
it could make prospectus rules much
lighter and it could tweak
solvency requirements for insurers if
the uk
deregulates too hard bad money would
drive out good
dodgy cowboys would replace honest
brokers
the uk has some form for laxity it lured
listings in the naughties from
asian resources groups some of their
business practices were as grubby as
their polluting products
today the city hopes for a green
makeover under the
fourth scenario the spires of gaia
odds five to one raising money for
renewable energy businesses is no harder
than doing it
for polluters you just need a critical
mass of capital
and expertise carbon transition is a
good
trend for london to embrace it's complex
involves large sums and will take a long
time it's a pity the uk has limited
credibility in green finance
the government has not issued green
bonds yet unlike other big eu countries
the uk stock market lacks big renewables
companies to match denmark's orested
london does have legacy hydrocarbons
businesses such as bp
and royal dutch shell which financiers
can help re-engineer
it also boasts a trade in carbon
derivatives
ice an exchange operates a futures
market in european emission permits
dealing in the equivalent of
12.2 gigatons of carbon yearly
unfortunately trading recently moved to
amsterdam because of brexit
similarly while the uk has some great
fintechs
the us will attract the listings while
valuations and liquidity
are higher there irish rooted payments
group stripe
plans to float in new york for the city
to thrive
the government must do more than
commission think pieces from torrid
peers
a national financial services strategy
is needed
margaret thatcher had a plan for the
city in 1986.
it was called big bang her successors
need to rethink london's financial
cluster again
things aren't so bad for the city the
refusal to grant equivalents
could take the eu down a self-defeating
path
in the past nationalistic financial
restrictions
in napoleonic europe and the u.s in the
1960s
were great for the city the higher the
walls a protectionist eu
builds to retain and control capital the
greater the amount that would go
elsewhere thanks for watching
to the end